dans l'université personne ne le
remarque
jessica n'est pas une étudiante comme
les autres
il ya neuf ans on lui a diagnostiqué un
dh un trouble de déficit de l'attention
au cégep en 2010 c'était un peu plus
tabou parce que ça commençait maintenant
à l'université les profs sont habitués
qu'ils sont super à l'aise ici je suis
qu'un étudiant en communication à l'uqam
elle va commencer prochainement une
maîtrise jamais elle n'aurait pensé se
rendre si loin
ces lectures qui depuis six mois c'est
ardu parce qu'elle est laide bouche
comme ça je dois lire avec une règle je
devine phrase je me rappelle plus de
caisse que viennent de lire des
étudiants avec un tdah on en compte de
plus en plus sur les campus depuis cinq
ans leur nombre a presque triplé
il est passé d'environ 2000 à 6000
on a vu cet étudiant l'arrivée sur le
campus massivement et d'ailleurs on les
a appelés que clientèle émergents à
l'université de montréal
ils sont près de 1000 auparavant j'ai
l'impression que ces étudiants là
abandonné au secondaire et ne se
rendaient pas l'université donc
maintenant comme il ya des plans
d'intervention qui sont mis en place
très tôt
ces étudiants là peuvent arriver à
l'université il ya dix ans j'étais
pratiquement suel services et maintenant
nous avons quatre psychologues 3
orthopédagogue et deux nouveaux
psychologue partout au québec les
universités sont confrontés au même
phénomène
les besoins sont tels qu elles ont des
mesures pour les accommoder à l'uqam
1300 étudiants ont besoin d'un coup de
pouce pour réussir ça peut être des
prises de notes aide à la prise de notes
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
courant dans toutes les universités
ça fait aussi pour mes examens seront
les examens à bord du dance flamand
terre donc mettre des conditions
nécessaires à leur réussite ici à l'uqam
un budget consacré à ces accommodements
vous avez ici un exemple de ce qui est
fait de notre salle permanente pour les
examens donc les étudiants par exemple
déjà on était déjà une valeur ici oui si
c'est dans le plan d'intervention
donc ça peut être du temps ça peut être
un local particulier jessica prend déjà
des médicaments pour améliorer sa
concentration
mais pour elle ce genre d'accommodement
est essentielle mais moi j'ai besoin de
cinq heures pour faire un examen on est
fatigué après elle en fait c'est pas si
c'est pas des bonus qu'on a c'est
vraiment pour nous emmener au même
niveau que les autres étudiants
malgré le fait que les étudiants doivent
obtenir un diagnostic rigoureux d'un
professionnel de la santé dans les
salles de cours ça ne plaît pas à tout
le monde
il yad'autres 18 ans étudiante qui se
demandent par exemple pourquoi une
personne a plus de temps pour faire un
examen pourquoi une personne a peut-être
une semaine de plus pour réaliser un
travail de session et ça peut créer des
situations un petit peu un petit peu
délicate certains professeurs il est
encore à offrir ce genre d'accommodement
sap est une méconnaissance ou une fausse
conception de penser que les exigences
du cours peuvent être abaissée pour ces
étudiants là alors que c'est pas du tout
le cas mais certains dans le milieu
universitaire se demande quel avenir
attend ses étudiants je pense qu'il faut
quand même dire assez ces étudiants
l'ont écouté les accommodements qu'on
accepte de vous de vous fournir vous ne
les aurez peut-être pas toujours et
quand vous serez sur le marché de
l'emploi
ça va peut-être compliqué vous allez
peut-être finalement avoir de sérieuses
difficultés à faire valoir que vous avez
besoin de conditions particulières pour
performer autant que vos collègues
quant à jesse cas elle entend compléter
sa maîtrise avec l'aide que lui offre
l'université qui me sens à ma place
je sens que je me donnais ma place et je
lis pris cette place là
[Musique]